hello this is presh talwalkar in this
video i'm going to show you how the
photomath smartphone app can solve many
math problems
we're going to take a look at sample
questions from the new york state test
8th grade common core math exam
these are questions they released in
august of 2014 which are sample
questions of what you'd see in a common
core exam
question one which number is equivalent
to three raised to the power four
divided by three raised to the power of
two
we're going to solve this problem using
the photo math smartphone app
on our phone we've loaded it
and now what we do is we simply hover
over the expression
and it tells us the answer instantly
which is nine
this is pretty cool
let's do another example of a question
determine the product
800.5
times 2 times 10 to the power of 6.
we'll once again get out the smartphone
photomath app
now the expression is a little bit
narrow so we can swipe to change the
window
we now put the window over the
expression and it instantly tells us the
answer is 1.061
times ten to the power of nine
so our answer is d
this is pretty cool but you could
probably solve those problems on a
regular calculator
let's take a look at another problem
what is the solution to the system of
equations below
three x plus four y equals minus two two
x minus four y equals minus eight
we'll swipe to get
the window
to be about the right size of the
rectangle for the equations
we'll hover over the system of equations
and instantly it will tell us the answer
is y equals one and x equals minus two
and we know the answer is d
let's try one more problem
solve the equation below
point four times the quantity two x plus
one half equals three
times the quantity point two x
plus minus two
minus four
not only do we have to solve it but we
have to show our work
we'll get out the window on the
smartphone
photomath app
we'll hover over the expression and
it tells us the answer is equal to minus
51.
but we need to show our work
no worries we click on the answer
and photomath gives you the step by step
derivation
for how you get x equals negative fifty
one
so although the smartphone photo app
will solve many problems i wanted to
give an example of here's a problem it
could not solve in fact the app could
only solve about 5 out of 32 questions
so there's still many problems it could
not solve and you still need to learn
math
but this app will help you
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can get my
books listed on my website catch me on
my blog mind your decisions catch mind
your decisions on facebook and google
plus you can also catch me at
preshtalwalkar on twitter instagram and
tumblr
and you can support me on patreon